Deanna is with us in Lexington hey
Deanna how are you I'm fine how are you
Dave and Chris better than I deserve how
can we help um my husband and I we are
investors we own our home we're out of
debt we had 403 B's both at work and I
have a Roth IRA he has a traditional RI
a but the sweet man insists on having
quite a large stash of cash in the
garage what's your street address how
much has he got in the garage um
approaching fifty thousand Oh lady ever
safe no well no but that's what um and
so I you know I've talked to him he
knows about you know inflation and your
money he wants to put it in a pickle jar
and bury it in the in the in the ground
so that fire doesn't get it but he's not
done that yet you know he's not I don't
he just feels I guess he just feels more
comfortable with that money in hand and
I would like to be able to present to
him some more reasons besides inflation
to you know change his mind a little bit
okay well well Deanna
listen I'm understand his point where he
wants to to have that safety net and
that feeling of having some money around
how old is he and it'd be seven okay
okay so here's what I would do I would
talk to him about number one you hit on
something the potential of a fire at the
home and the loss of their money the
inflation I love that you mentioned that
because you and I know that money just
sitting there and buried in the ground
that 50,000 will look more like 25,000
here in about ten years and so in
looking at that I think he's trying to
have some security so there's a couple
of ways he could do that maybe he could
keep five thousand and a safe we know we
need to get us safe on post and more
importantly and let's take the other
forty five thousand and let's go take it
in the bank
he can keep his bank statement with him
at all times and kind of look at that
and go visit it on the weekends if he
wants but but but but let's get it out
of there just because it's risk and and
I think the inflation side of things
that you're losing money each day that
it's sitting there let me give you a
really sad story I actually had a call
or several years ago
Blake's reminded me of it for a tease
and they're working as producer right
now a guy buried $25,000 in cash and
coffee can in his backyard and what you
don't know about paper is it
disintegrates and the money just
disintegrated became dirt oh my when
they dug it up I couldn't it wasn't even
enough showing to turn it in for other
money he lost all the money oh and let's
go ahead and add this up for a second
okay if you put 50,000 bucks in a mutual
fund and if the mutual fund averaged 12%
at 57 years old at 77 years old you'd
have five hundred and forty thousand
dollars in there
this is a four hundred and ninety
thousand dollar pile of stupid I know I
know right now I'll write those numbers
down at 77 you'd have five hundred and
forty thousand bucks if you never added
anything to this account and so it's
costing me and how much five hundred and
forty thousand dollars is what fifty
thousand dollars turns into if you put
it in a mutual fund and leave it alone
for 20 years a good made a good mutual
fund that's making good money okay right
not not not just any mutual fund but I
mean if you made to us on your money
that's what it'd be if it makes less
it'd be less but the point still is this
is a four hundred plus thousand dollar
mistake all right and I don't think you
guys you got an extra 400 thousand throw
around no okay if you do then this is
okay yeah but you're not only going to
end up losing the fifty thousand if you
bury it in the backyard or if the house
burns or when a burglar goes through
your garage one of the three or the dog
gets in it who knows I mean you're going
to losing this money if you had a really
good safe I'd feel better but you still
have that missed opportunity cost on
what that money would grow to and that's
the downside of this how much is in your
all's totalistic today and we're a
we're approaching 600,000 with our
retirement and and then our home is
worth about two hundred thousand if he
wants to keep a strong cash stash at
that level you can afford to do it not
fifty thousand though I wouldn't suggest
that at your all's level but you know
ten thousand bucks or something in a
really nice safe I'm not going to gripe
at him too much about that that's going
to give him a comfort level but fifty
thousand in the garage has stupid on it
at three minute three or four different
levels so it's just it's just bad it's
it's it's a it's really it's it's
irresponsible another way to ask him is
this I'm just making this up as I go you
can tell but ask him if he owned money
and he gave it to someone to manage for
him and that's what they did with it how
would he feel about that because you're
actually managing this money for God
right right yeah and if you read the
parable the talents got buried in the
backyard didn't come out real good
I know you are correct so I would I
would dig that one up too you know bring
it throw a Bible in there just for the
fun of it but you know if you were
managing your management money for God
so if you were managing if someone if
you gave someone fifty thousand dollars
of your money to manage and they kept in
the garage and didn't invest it how
would you feel about me and God can't be
like thrilled about this I just it's not
it's not a it's not very responsible no
so in it and in freedom back I'm like
Chris I get why he's doing it cuz I'm an
old redneck we all read next we like
having some cash around you know yeah
but he's got a little bit too much you
know not not his neck yep not too red
yes beyond too much cash so let's be
smart with it let's protect that I like
what you said Dave there's nothing wrong
with keeping some money outside because
they obviously have done things the
right way I mean they're approaching a
million dollars net worth and if you
were to put forty five of that into a
gross mutual fund like you mentioned
he's going to be well over a million in
time so let's let the money work for you
you worked hard for it
let's be smart and protected yeah that's
just yeah listen to your wife she's
smart
and you know spouses really do enter
into this equation on retirement in
general you really do and when they when
we're do it when you're doing this stuff
at the smart conference it comes up
doesn't it it really does I think when
we we start to look at this I want
people I want to encourage people out
there to think of your home as a home
team everybody has a role everybody has
a position to play in that in that in
that team being successful and we're the
team we're talking about your family and
when you look at things through the
family filter what I want you to do is
to do everything you can in the best
interest of the family and that means
husbands and wives working together and
if you're single you find an
accountability partner if you're newly
single you find an accountability
partner somebody that cares enough and
loves you enough and wants you to be
successful
but we got to play our role and you got
above all stay in your lane do the
things you're designed to do but a
please please work together talk about
this your retirement dream should unite
you it should inspire you to move
forward because I know you can do it go
to Chris Hogan 360 comm and look at the
are IQ your retire inspired quotient
your retirement IQ you need to know what
your number is and what you note your
number is and you can get on track to
getting there Chris can show you how get
follow him on Facebook and Twitter at
Chris Hogan 360 Chris thanks for hanging
out with me thank you for having me do
this is the Dave Ramsey show